a good plan executed today is better
than the perfect plan executed next week
or next year I think one of the biggest
challenges for Content creators and
entrepreneurs in the modern age is
distraction success leaves Clues this
would be studying other successful
YouTube channels studying other content
formats that are winning studying other
victories so that you can have victories
of your own so here are four unbreakable
YouTube tips for winning the war for
views
I don't know about you but it can be
very overwhelming when you think about
the sheer size of the YouTube platform
how many videos are uploaded every
single day and how much competition
there is so the question is how do you
stand out amongst the competition how do
you get notice in a crowded Marketplace
and how do you ultimately position your
YouTube channel to win I'm very excited
about this series that we're doing here
on the think media podcast which is
called the Battleground for views tips
from military generals for winning the
war for views and this is actually based
on some material from famous military
generals that you'd be surprised is
incredibly relevant for us as YouTube
content creators why well because
ultimately to be successful on YouTube
or business it's important to learn as
much as you can about strategy and
tactics that can give you an edge over
your competitors in many ways ensuring
that survival and success of your
YouTube channel in a competitive
environment is not dissimilar to
ensuring the survival and success of a
military unit on the battlefield our
text today is called on war one of the
most famous books on Military strategy
from General Carl Von klauschwitz the
military campaigns that he was active in
were happening in the late 1700s and
early 1800s and then years later after
his death his wife compiled his
information into this powerful book that
we can use as content creators so here
are four unbreakable YouTube tips for
winning the war for views number one
Perfection is the enemy of progress
here's the quote from the book The Enemy
of a good plan is the dream of a perfect
plan friend I don't know about you but I
need to hear this a lot of times I wait
around for Perfection when what I need
to do is get to work one of the biggest
mistakes that I see holding people back
when it comes to starting in their
YouTube channel is not starting their
YouTube channel why because they're
waiting for a perfect plan one of the
biggest things that holds even
successful content creators and business
owners back is previous successes and
now they're waiting for Perfection
because there may be shrinking back in
fear of loss when ultimately a good plan
executed today is better than the
perfect plan executed next week or next
year number two don't quit too soon
here's the quote many assume that half
efforts can be effective a small jump is
easier than a large one but no one
wishing to cross a wide ditch would
cross half of it first I'm convinced
that the majority of content creators
that start a YouTube channel start to
feel discouraged and then give up they
quit too soon and they give up too
easily the truth is it takes a lot of
energy time persistence and consistency
to ultimately reach escape velocity to
all ultimately build momentum on YouTube
and the problem with halfway efforts is
exactly what the quote said it's like
trying to jump over an entire ditch but
only giving it a halfway effort where
you're going to fall in the middle
you're going to get stuck in the slump
and so of course there's a time to quit
there is a time to Pivot your channel we
actually have a dedicated think media
podcast episode about that that I'll
link up in the show notes if you've
given it adequate time adequate uploads
adequate energy adequate strategy and
it's not working yet yet then maybe you
should give up but I'm certain that 99
of people have not done the former
things that I've mentioned the key here
is don't quit too soon number three
study history here's the quote examples
from history make everything clear and
furnish the best description of proof in
the empirical Sciences examples from
history make everything clear and
furnish the best description of roof in
the empirical Sciences this applies with
more Force to the Art of War than to any
other so why would this be relevant to
YouTube well number one I think it's
important to study mistakes you've
probably heard that those who fail to
learn from history are doomed to repeat
it but I also think it's important to
study victories those who ignore
history's victories will not have
victories of their own here at the think
media podcast we like to say success
leaves Clues this would be studying
other successful YouTube channels
studying other content formats that are
winning studying other victories so that
you can have victories of your own this
is also true for mistakes and the cool
thing is that YouTube has been around
long enough that there are historical
examples that we can learn from there's
a great video that will link up in the
description that tells the story of a
media company in an entertainment
channel that was one of the most early
influential YouTube channels on the
platform Collective of people got
together and started making content
eventually they started to work with a
larger company that kind of invested and
bought them and then a lot of drama
followed there was a lot of ups and
downs and I found when I think about the
YouTube channel I want to build and the
media company I want to build that this
was one of the most valuable videos I've
ever seen and there's now thousands of
tales of creators who have come and have
gone who've had 15 minutes of fame
who've gotten into different vices or
trouble or had different challenges that
have came with the pressure of YouTube
those who failed to learn from history
are doomed to repeat it and ultimately
if you're listening to this podcast
you're not really just a YouTube Creator
you're more of an entrepreneur you're an
influencer you're a thought leader even
if you're just aspiring to these things
and you're somebody who's being followed
you're a leader and so there is endless
Tales From history of successes and
failures of leaders of successes and
failures of celebrities of how they've
reinvented themselves reinvented their
careers of the successes and failures of
different businesses makes me think of
FTX there's a lot to learn in that rise
and fall of Sam bakeman freed and that
story somebody recently called me a
YouTube OG which is probably true I mean
the first channel I started was for my
local church an hour north of Seattle in
2007 just two years after YouTube
started so now I've been on YouTube 16
years I've been producing video for 20
years and I've had the privilege of
actually observing people come and go on
the platform one of the things I've seen
is I've seen family vloggers come and go
I've seen some of them not being able to
sustain their success and having that 15
minutes of fame but I've also seen some
very sad stories of families under the
pressure of Fame and of the accolades
and the amount of people sliding in
their DMS Affairs have happened divorces
have happened people have blown up their
family they've cheated on their spouse
I've seen people be crazy with money and
ultimately crack under the pressure that
can come with a YouTube career but this
is the opportunity that you and I have
we can learn from history not just so
that we can avoid the mistakes but also
that we can learn the lessons from the
successes so that we can have victories
of our own number four focus is power
here's the quote there is no higher and
simpler law of strategy than that of
keeping one's forces concentrated here's
another one pursue one great decisive
aim with force and determination I think
one of the biggest challenges for
Content creators and entrepreneurs in
the modern age is distraction it's
chasing too many projects too many ideas
if you try and Chase two rabbits you end
up catching neither of them and this is
why I love studying military strategy
because this same strategy is so
relevant to YouTube there is no higher
or simpler law of strategy then keeping
your forces concentrated keeping your
energy concentrated keeping your brand
concentrated keeping your Niche
concentrated what do you want to be
known for why are people following you
if you talk about 10 different topics
over 10 different days and 10 different
levels of energy from 10 different
Vantage points people don't even know
what you're talking about they don't
know what you stand for who you are
because you're all over the place it
would be similar to doing a military
campaign and having your forces divided
across Enemy Lines so that everyone's
alone as opposed to concentrated pursue
one great decisive aim with force and
determination what is the great decisive
aim of your YouTube channel what is the
Clear Vision of your online business
what is the one goal what is the one
thing that you are pursuing and by
defining that then you can align your
course in your determination behind that
one goal I don't want to chase 10
rabbits because not only will I not
catch any of them but I'll be exhausted
I'll be frantic I'll be scattered as we
can learn from military strategy more
relevant to YouTube than it ever has
been before focuses power and if you
actually are feeling like you need some
help with Focus I don't blame you I know
that for me it was hard to get clarity
it was hard to really build a cohesive
strategy and really get clear on what is
my strategy for my YouTube channel my
online business maybe you're trying to
take your existing business and think
about how you're going to position that
on YouTube if you want help with that we
have a free class at
thinkmasterclass.com I'll tell you a
little bit more about that in a second
but think about how this could be
applied to your Niche that's one area
right it could be that focus is power in
your online brand what do you want to be
known for what is the thing you want to
be known for there's a book called the
one thing I think by Gary Keller the
founder I think of Keller Williams the
real estate kind of Empire and it could
be related to the one thing you want to
be known for but again I want to ask you
the question what is your bigger Vision
what is the decisive aim what does
winning look like is winning ultimately
just views or do you have some Revenue
targets Do you want to build a product
or a service where do you want to be in
three years five years ten years this is
the Battleground for views we're
learning tips from military generals for
winning the war of the competitive
landscape that we're facing online those
that have Focus are always going to
outperform and have an advantage over
those that are random and Scattered with
their efforts that are random and
Scattered with their Vision that are
launching 10 different businesses over
10 days what about the person who
focuses on the one business idea over 10
years concentrate your focus and again
if you want more help with that check
out these show notes or go to
thinkmasterclass.com where you can kind
of sit with me over my shoulder and I
will help you put together a smart
YouTube strategy so that you can go from
scattered to focused and maybe even
you're feeling a little confused when it
comes to your approach to YouTube right
now we're going to go from confusion to
Clarity so thinkmasterclass.com is where
you can check out that free on-demand
class now General Klaus wits has a final
word of inspiration for us in just a
second but I want to thank you for
listening to this episode and if you
found it valuable could you like rate
and review the think media podcast
wherever you watch or listen and
definitely subscribe to this series we
have multiple episodes on this concept
of winning the war from views we're
going to be learning from Sun Tzu the
famous book The Art of War and some
other powerful quotes and strategies
from different military generals that
are super relevant for YouTube let me
leave you with this final quote from the
general if the leader is filled with
high ambition and if he pursues his aims
with audacity and strength of will he
will reach them in spite of all
obstacles